foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday November 30th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
over the last couple of years Insurance
firms have slowly been Gathering a
clearer picture of what cyber attacks
cost their clients
a few major incidents like the not petia
virus that invaded corporate software in
2017 or the attack on the colonial
pipeline last year have shown just how
big the Fallout from cyber attacks can
be
but there still hasn't been a truly
catastrophic Cyber attack
so how is the Cyber insurance industry
preparing for one
joining us to discuss that is wsj pro
cyber security reporter James Rundle hi
James thanks for joining us Hey Zoe
thanks for having me so James since 2020
we've seen this big pickup in the number
of claims for cyber attacks how have
insurance companies been adjusting their
policies to deal with this yeah
particularly from 2020 there was a huge
uptick in claims basically from cyber
attacks of all Stripes whether that's
ransomware or other forms and
it really knocked the insurance industry
back a little bit I think a lot of
insurers got into cyber thinking it was
a really lucrative source of Revenue but
then as the claims started to pile up
they started to look at it and realize
that actually we're not being as
disciplined without under icing as maybe
we should be so in reaction to that
premiums went up across the board by
significant amounts and insurers already
started asking more of the people who
wanted to be policyholders they wanted
to know exactly what kind of cyber
defenses they had in place and what
level of protections they were putting
to secure their systems in and they were
refusing cover for people who didn't
have it okay so higher standards for the
people who are purchasing these cyber
insurance policies but how do insurers
determine you know what the payout
should be when there is a Cyber attack
well it depends on the level of coverage
you buy I mean cyber Insurance generally
covers a number of areas so you'll have
your initial instant response so you
might have to hire a cyber security
company to come in and find out what
happens you have the legal counsel you
need to retain in order to meet any
regulatory obligations you have
communications for crisis scenarios and
everything else there is a whole battery
of costs that are involved in that
depending on the size of the
organization of course those costs will
increase or decrease accordingly so even
with the growing number of policies out
there and with the growing number of
payouts that insurers have had to make
there's still this concern that they're
not prepared for a catastrophic Cyber
attack can you I guess start by sort of
telling us what a catastrophic Cyber
attack would actually mean how does that
compare to other cyber attacks because
I'm sure some companies would feel
pretty catastrophic when they've been
hit absolutely and I think it's
important to stress that we don't
actually know because we haven't had one
yet when we talk about catastrophic
hacks we're not talking about
a single company being taken down or a
Cyber attack that causes you know
several million dollars in damage which
is you know pretty catastrophic for
those involved but what we're talking
about here is something that really
affects the economy or affects the
stability of society so we're the
collapse of the financial system for
instance or exchanges being taken down
Clearing Houses things are vital to the
running of the country that if they were
to stop working the country would
effectively stop working as well which
is why it's one of those things that
people hope doesn't happen but they're
worried will eventually I mean can you
give us an example of what one of those
companies is because we have seen
Fallout from you know a Cyber attack on
one company affect other companies
we have one of the scenarios that the
people I speak to my article are working
on is what happens if one of the major
Cloud providers gets taken down so
you're talking like an Amazon here or a
Google or a Microsoft or someone like
that because these people don't just
power one company in a specific industry
where there would be some Downstream
effects they power huge amounts of
companies across huge numbers of
critical infrastructure sectors whether
that's Finance retail Logistics
Healthcare that if they were to go down
it would have severe repercussions
across a range of areas so given that we
haven't had one of these catastrophic
cyber attacks how do insurers make
models of what they might be dealing
with in that scenario well that's the
big question it's what they're
struggling with right now the problem is
cyber security as an area to ensure is
something called the contagion effect
which what we've been alluding to where
the impact of an attack on one company
can have far-reaching consequences among
many many others and it takes a
incredible degree of complex mathematics
to be able to even attempt to model how
that would happen and the fact of the
matter is you just don't know you don't
know how one company being taken down
will affect another which in turn will
affect another which in turn will affect
another it's extraordinarily difficult
to try and figure out exactly what would
happen if the bank of England would be
taken down or the London Stock Exchange
or the New York Stock Exchange
simultaneously or something like that
much harder is that to model than say
like a category five hurricane where you
might have a lot of Fallout and one
thing could affect another could take
out homes and power grids I mean they do
have some precedent right well that's
the thing we have had category five
hurricanes before and we've had natural
disasters before on Epic scales that we
have the data where we can look at that
and say okay well historically this is
what happened and we can use that to
extrapolate what would happen now and
our more connected society and
everything else the issue with cyber
security is that we simply don't have
that information we only have small
relatively small scale events that we
can use to guess what would happen on a
larger scale but the truth is we just
don't know and we were talking about
this ripple effect where you know one
company faces a Cyber attack and it
affects all these other Downstream
companies but are insurers thinking
about what the impact on them might be I
mean how do they prepare for the
potential risk to their business if this
happens for sure that's the big
existential question really is if one of
these were to happen would it be so
large as to actually take down the
carriers themselves would they not be
able to cover their obligations and the
claims in this instance or the
reinsurers who ensure the insurers you
know what would they be on the hook for
as well and so we started to see some
moves towards an element of risk
management in this area Lloyds of London
which is not an insurer but is a
significant Marketplace for insurers
recently directed its syndicates to
adopt language that would exclude
state-backed catastrophic attacks from
their insurance policies because as we
said the risk is so great they simply
don't know how the industry would cope
it would be a systemic event not just
for society but for the insurance
industry as well we're also starting to
see I mean from my reporting people were
telling me that
some insurers are excluding specific
Cloud providers from their coverage
saying you know something goes wrong
we'll only cover up to a certain amount
of Damages or we will not cover if this
happens so they are starting to look at
this and think okay well we need to put
some limits in place we need to put some
exclusions in place to make sure that
we're protected as well and that we can
provide the services that we're offering
all right that's our reporter James
Rundle James thanks so much for
explaining this for us thanks sir and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories check out our
website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]